and the panelists today are all going to
speak about evidence-based interventions
we have people from the federal level
state level community-based organization
and and from research science and we'll
start with Charles Collins who some of
you may know Charles is the section
chief and the capacity building unit in
the HIV division at the Centers for
Disease Control he has worked with a
team of 11 behavioral scientists on
disseminating and helping organizations
to integrate effective interventions and
particularly the 25 that's so called
Debbie's that are considered the most
effective and he with no further ado
Charles is going to talk to you about
that and then we'll go on to Barry
thanks thank you very much well thank
you very much for having me here today
and I'm going to talk a little bit about
the the Debbie project a CDC project
that is is in March had its seventh year
in operation and so let me just talk a
little bit about some of the the the
steps that we do in that process and
some of the interventions that's what
that's the part that I'm going to cover
today first of all the we really would
like to make sure that when when
programs apply for funding that they
have a document that describes the
intervention that stands as an agreement
between the centers for disease control
and the funded agency that we fund and
so for each of the Debbie interventions
we develop a roughly 11 to 13 page
summary of that intervention which we
post on the CDC website and that's the
procedural guidance for our
interventions all right so that's where
we post our interventions and any
intervention that we indicate in a
program announcement that we're going to
fund it will be included in in the
procedural guide the second website or
the second point down there is our this
is our resource website it's the Debbie
website and I'm going to talk a little
bit about that at the very end of the
presentation but it is the method by
which people register for training for
various interventions they can also
download materials and we're constantly
putting new materials on that website so
that people can have resources around
behavioral interventions now we use a
eight step model for disseminating
interventions and sending them from the
research community out into the practice
community so the first step of this is
planning we want to find out from
communities what are the interventions
that they need and so we listen to
community as to what are the
interventions that they think would work
in their community and then we begin to
try to match that to the publications
that are coming out of the scientific
community the second step that we take
in this process is that we plan with the
researchers which when we begin to take
an intervention and we begin to
distribute it and move it out into
community we ask the researcher for
their help in planning that process in
many cases the researcher has already
begun the diffusion process they've
already began begun to distribute their
materials that they've developed we also
talked to the 50 aids drew state aids
directors around the United States we
asked them what are what are this will
call the aids director of Mississippi
the aids director of Alaska will say
what are the interventions that Alaska
needs what are the interventions that
Mississippi needs what are your training
needs so we go through and ask that so
we really look just try to develop a
planning approach that includes multiple
stages including the researchers
communities as well as the health
departments around the country our next
step is hell
the marketing and that is to begin to
market the interventions to executive
directors of cbos and begin to market
the interventions to program directors
of community-based organizations and to
also ask them what kind of materials do
you need to help make a decision around
this intervention so many times people
will say well I'd like to see a budget
or if I'm going to have to hire three
staff to work on this intervention I'd
like to see job descriptions or someone
would say well if I'm going to do this
intervention I'd like a logic model so
we develop these materials and make them
accessible so that communities can make
decisions about interventions we also
developed a training course which were
distributing around the United States on
how to select an evidence-based
intervention for your target population
that also meets the needs of that your
agency can implement so it helps people
think through how do I meet the needs of
my community in an intervention that my
that an intervention that my agency can
actually implement policy incentives is
our third step and that is at the
federal level to make sure that our
program announcements indicate that we
will support evidence-based
interventions that we will give grants
out to evidence-based interventions at
this point we spend 55 million dollars a
year that we give to community-based
organizations to do evidence-based
interventions and this will continue I
will tell you that this will continue as
a CDC strategy that we will continue to
support at roughly that level of cbos in
the field who are doing evidence-based
practice the fourth step is packaged
design we considered the packages that
we develop around these interventions to
be living documents you know there's a
philosophy there's different
philosophies about what is an
intervention and there is a more
conservative philosophy that this
intervention was was developed and
tested in a couple of with a couple of
agencies and it has these core elements
and that everything has to be done
exactly the way the research was done
and there's another possibly more
liberal approach to thinking about what
is an intervention and you have to think
about that an intervention as it passes
from community to community and people
begin to think about what is the meaning
of this innovation for my people what is
the end of what is this what does this
innovation mean for my agency this is a
more of the Debbie approach so that when
we hear about people doing a working on
the Debbie interventions and they have
lessons learned we try to incorporate
the lessons that they learn into into
our process we try to capture products
that are done one of our interventions
is of intervention cost sista for
example which was originally for African
American women well there's a
community-based organization in in
Boston who their target population is
Haitian women who are recent immigrants
to the United States so they took the
cysts intervention and they translated
it into creo and they started developing
art and and other materials in that so
that the intervention would be
attractive to Haitian women so you know
I mean as soon as we heard about this we
call it said we want that product we
would love to have that product because
we understand there's a CBO in New
Orleans that also works with Haitian
immigrants and we would like to make
sure that they get that product that you
translated up in Boston so our approach
to 22 interventions is one a very fluid
approach in terms of working with
community and dialogue in terms of
understanding how these interventions
can be used in multiple settings with
multiple populations with multiple
resources and conditions the fifth part
of this is training um and that is that
we do believe that you have to have more
than just the package to do the
intervention we do believe that you need
to go through a three four or five-day
training depending on the complexity of
the intervention to learn how to
actually implement what is in the in the
package we also have capacity building
and technical assistance available
we're just about to fund a new family of
community-based excuse me of capacity
building providers we're going to be
spending thirty two million dollars a
year on capacity building to build a
capacity of cbos around the country and
clinics and health departments to be
able to sustain evidence-based practice
we do quality assurance and that is
there's there's a broad range of quality
assurance aspects to this but one aspect
of this is we just want to make sure
that we have good trainers who get up
and teach the curricula and are able to
get across the information to the people
in the audience and so this is one of
our main quality assurance steps finally
evaluation we have evaluation at
multiple ranges in going all the way
from looking at process evaluation and
fidelity to the to the core activities
of the intervention all the way to
looking at the outcomes that some of our
community-based organizations are able
to achieve there are two round 22 to 23
hundred cbos in the United States and so
our philosophy is not that we expect all
23 hundred of these agencies to do
really outcome evaluation or outcome
monitoring if you're doing
evidence-based practice and you are
doing the intervention as we have taught
you to do we are not that concerned with
outcome monitoring we like to do
Sentinel approaches to outcome
monitoring if you have 2300 agencies
doing evidence-based practice you can go
in and randomly select 10 that are doing
sista 10 that are doing healthy
relationships chin that are doing
partnership for health and you can look
and see what is the outcome variance
that's happening in the field and so
this is this is the step where added in
terms of our evaluation processes in
evolution well let's talk about the
intervention so the first thing the
first those eight steps was are a
dissemination model and now I'm going to
talk a little bit about some of the the
trunk the the interventions that go
through this too
emanation model well we have some
interventions that really are designed
to be adapted for all populations of the
community promises the one is probably
the most obvious of these community
promises an intervention that's based on
role model stories that show people
moving through the stages of change
towards new healthier behaviors or
leaving behind unhealthy behaviors and
so these role model stories can be
written in any language they can be
written for any target behavior they can
be written to to match the culture of
any community and so it's an
intervention that can be used for
multiple multiple purposes to help
people think through the process of
moving through the stages of change
towards more protective behavior and
then of course there's our project
respect this is our intervention that
was originally tested along with as a
pretest post-test model for for behavior
change but it's a model that indicates
if you use a client centered approach
with people around what are their
behavioral goals that they wish to
change that you can help people change
their risk behavior if it's in a
supportive one on one type of client
centered approach we have a range of
interventions for men who have sex with
men the first of these is our popular
opinion leader developed by Jeff Kelly
um it is it's a social network approach
to intervention the most the most common
misunderstanding when we communicate
with community-based organizations about
the popular opinion leader is they think
that the popular opinion leaders are
outreach workers and that is that is
that is not right and so I'm just going
to take a second to distinguish them a
popular opinion leader is a person
identified in a social network who
through their communication and their
relationships with their friends and
their family and the people that they
interact with can persuade other people
about some value about some norm of
some behavior their influence is with
people that they know and they need to
be volunteers and they really should not
be paid they should do this as a natural
relaxed approach to working with their
friends and associates outreach workers
on the other hand are people that are
usually employed and you ask them to
talk to strangers you ask them to go
into high-risk neighborhoods you ask
them to distribute condoms brochures do
risk assessment so we point out that
they are so the pol the popular opinion
leader and the outreach worker are very
different and they may in fact
complement each other but they're very
different approaches to do an HIV
prevention in community d up is our
african-american MSM adaptation of the
popular opinion leader we had an
outbreak of HIV in North Carolina among
african-american MSM we went in the
state of North Carolina said what can we
do about this and the CDC recommended
doing the popular opinion leader in the
state of North Carolina using their
historic black colleges in partnership
with the with their community based
organizations and what they did was they
took the popular opinion leader and
adapted it in terms of artwork in terms
of training sessions etc so that it was
more appealing for young black gay men
and so we have a version of the popular
opinion leader called D up that we're
now diffusing around the country the
third of these as many men many voices
it started out as an intervention that
was an adaptation of Jeff Kelly's Ares
study that he did back in 1989 however
it was it was culturally modified for
black gay men and we've done some
testing recently we just had a new
publication on many men many voices done
as a weekend retreat so that people
would leave a bus would pick up 10 12
game in black came in on Friday and go
do a weekend retreat bring them back on
Sunday evening and they would get the
full dose of the inner
vention at a state park or some other
site where they could go through the
whole intervention in a weekend
empowerment is our intervention
developed by Susan K Gillis this
intervention is an intervention it's a
multi-component intervention this Susan
K glasses is is one of my heroes she is
she's so sensitive to working with the
risk community and thinking about the
design of interventions she started
talking to young gay men and saying what
what would it take to get you to go to a
community-based organization and get
some prevention and young gay men were
saying I wouldn't go there for anything
I wouldn't be caught dead in a CBO you
know I would never go to a CBO so she
said well what would you do that in
terms of prevention what would make you
get involved in prevention and they said
well if I could find a way to meet other
young game in and so you know so she
said well then let's develop an
intervention that has that dynamic to it
so her intervention it has got some nice
features one of the things about her
intervention that I think is
underestimated is the fact that her
intervention is really in many ways a
community-building intervention so it
has some real strengths in that regard
also we have some interventions for
women these include the real AIDS
prevention project it's an intervention
that uses a range of activities
including role model stories outreach
workers peer volunteers and a one-time
educational group for women so it uses
multiple strategies together in that
intervention we have the sistah
intervention developed by Adi Clemente
and wind good and intervention for
african-american women that uses the
theory of gender and power is one of the
basis for the intervention the
intervention posits that men and our
culture frequently have more sexual
power than women they get they make more
decisions around whether the condom is
used where the condom is not used well
if that's the case how do we in fact
help women with sexual negotiation
skills so that they can begin to work
with their male partner to get the male
partner to use a condom
and and so it's it's an intervention and
you know one of the things that D
Clemente and wind good found in their
original formative research was when
they started talking to women about how
do you convince a man to use a condom
the fear was loss of femininity so that
women said I want to be able to convince
my male partner to use a condom but I
don't want to come across as as
aggressive I want to I want to remain
feminine in that so the intervention
helps balance that process of how do you
do sexually negotiate and still have the
woman feel that she is acting in a
feminine manner to her male sex partner
the willow intervention is also
developed by D Clemente and when good
and it is for hiv-positive women it has
a cope and stressing component to that
intervention and then finally our Sister
to Sister intervention I put it here on
the list because we're beginning to
defuse it now we're just starting it's
an intervention which was developed by
loretta Jamaat and loretta jamaat is on
the faculty of a nursing school sure her
PhD is in nursing and so she's very
interested in what role nurses could
play in terms of helping to change risk
behavior so she developed in it I mean
everybody in this room has gone to the
doctor and there's an ER and a nurse
comes in they take your temperature they
take your blood pressure they say why
are you here to see the doctor they all
write it in the chart and then they
leave you for 15 minutes before the
doctor comes back in the room into the
examination room so what Loretta Jamaat
said well why don't we use that 15
minutes why don't we ask nurses to
educate women who are coming in to see a
physician and let's use some of this
time before the physician comes into the
examination room to educate people about
their their risks and help them with
protective behaviors now we do have some
debbie's for injecting drug users we
have fin roads as safety counts it's an
intervention that uses an outreach team
and also a team that's within the agency
it involves social events for active
drug users it was found to work with
both injecting active injecting drug
users
and crack cocaine smokers it is a harm
reduction intervention in that each
client gets to choose their own risk
behavior if a client comes in and says I
have 16 sex partners a month and my goal
is to move to 15 or someone says I'm
injecting cocaine seven days a week and
you know what my goal is to at least not
inject on Sundays you know what that is
wonderful in that intervention it's a
harm reduction philosophy and people are
encouraged if they need to to take small
steps towards their behavior change we
have our first intervention which was
actually developed by a spanish-speaking
researcher all of her staff spoke
Spanish and all of the clients in the
study were Spanish the intervention was
developed in San Juan Puerto Rico it's
by dr. Rafael Robles and it's an
intervention that uses the case
management model with injecting drug
users to help them also on a range of
behaviors around Risk Reduction around
seeking treatment if that is a goal that
they would like to be involved in we
also have the clear intervention
developed by a mary-jane Roth from Boris
it's for HIV positive young drug users
and so we developed this model clear as
a prevention case management model so
that people could go through the
intervention and would be supported and
behavior change one-on-one with their
counselor we have several for HIV
positives I've mentioned a couple of
these before so it won't I can go
through this slide pretty quickly one of
these is healthy relationships it was
developed by Seth calamon for
hiv-positive men and women it's a group
level intervention that uses motion
picture film clips to stimulate
discussion around status disclosure
self-efficacy around status disclosure
and then moving on towards safer sex
practices there's also partnership for
health developed by Jean Richardson it's
an intervention that's delivered by the
physician
to the HIV positive patient with each
and every clinic visit it's meant to be
a four-minute intervention where the
physician has four minutes of messaging
to their patient with each visit we have
two for heterosexual adults we have
voices in which we have both in English
and a Spanish version of voices now how
many I just just how many people have
been trained in voices or have ever seen
the voices films in the audience raise
your hand okay so a few of you have the
voices intervention was developed by
Lydia Donald but she developed the
intervention about 12 years ago and
needless to say people now look at the
video and go oh my god people don't talk
like that anymore or you know that's
looking and say look at that hair on
that lady you know and so so what we've
done is we've gone in and we've taken
and redone the the intervention and so
we now have a new voices package that
has updated DVDs we're moving from video
to DVD and so and so we have now have
the dvds for the new voices intervention
now just to give you an idea about how
many people are using the interventions
across the country we announced that for
the voices intervention that we had a
new lease new DVDs and if any CBO was
doing voices let us know on our website
and we would send you the the new voices
materials we had 450 cbos tell us that
they were doing the voices intervention
and asking us for the new materials we
also have kinect kinect was developed by
susan Wiggy and nabeel elba cell at
Columbia University it's an intervention
that works with heterosexual couples
Latino couples and african-american
couples so we're working now to begin to
defuse that intervention our ones for
youth includes street smarts by Roth
remorse for homeless and runaway youth
we have an intervention here by Bonnie's
Stanton called focus on youth which
works with african-american young people
who are in this
seventh eighth and ninth grade and
there's an impact video and the impact
video goes to their parents so you're
working with the youth and then you're
also working with the with the parents
and Stanton's Bonnie Stanton's
intervention and then finally d Clemente
in wind good she'll a intervention it is
for young sexually active females
between the ages of 14 and 18 it is not
meant to be an intervention for virgins
it's meant to be an intervention for for
women who are young women very young
women who are sexually active d clemente
and wind good when they began doing
their their formative work and focus
groups and they started interviewing
young women who were 14 15 and 16 who
were having sex one of the questions was
was well how old is your boyfriend what
they found frequently was that the
boyfriend was 10 years older so that the
girl was 15 she's in the ninth grade she
has a boyfriend who's 25 who has a job
who has a car so in many ways he has so
much more power than she has power in
terms of money power in terms of status
power because we give males more power
so how do you work with a
fifteen-year-old ninth grader so that
she's able to negotiate with a 25 year
old boyfriend to convince him to use a
condom we have our first prison
intervention it's called Project start
it's an intervention that has two
sessions with the prisoners before
they're paroled and for after all right
let me go and finish my last two slides
and just the first of these is at the
very beginning of our talk I said that
there are people at community-based
organizations ask us for resources so
these are the kind of resources we try
to put on our website starter kits so
that you can have an idea of what to do
the first 90 days that you're doing the
intervention budgets a logic models
technical assistance guides or
evaluation manuals so your evaluator can
think about how to evaluate your program
and then just some final results as to
the number of people trained in the in
the last seven years we've done over 700
Debbie training seven
36 and we've trained over 8,000
employees of over 2,200 CBO's in the
United States but the health departments
have also played a major role we've got
over 1595 employees of other over 255
health departments across the country
who have been partners thank you very
much Thank You Charles and I have to say
that that I didn't really do justice to
all of the work Charles has done in his
introduction in the interest of time but
if you look at his biosketch you can see
that he's done his own research he's
published and he has numerous
publications that I would encourage you
to look at that that are really geared
toward adapting research in the practice
setting but we are going to allow a few
questions after each presentation so we
we have about five minutes if people
have questions for Charles right now
okay was it oh I'm sorry I'm sorry yes
Robin
sure sure the first question is
addressing the issue around MSM and
we're trying to address that issue of
new interventions for MSM by stimulating
the development of new interventions or
the adoption or adaption of previous
intervention-- specifically for MSM of
color so for example right now we're
working with Susan keg lists to to do an
adaptation of the empowerment
intervention and to do that intervention
in in to southern cities that have large
black gay populations and so we're
trying to build our portfolio of
interventions out for MSM but
particularly for Latino MSM Asian
Pacific Islander MSM and
african-american MSM we don't have we
honestly do not have enough
interventions and we do think that we
need more in that in that population at
the beginning of the AIDS epidemic a lot
of HIV prevention I think was a natural
process of people being shocked by this
disease they were their friends were
dying it had an incredible societal
impact and so many of the interventions
that were the Debbie interventions were
tested and developed prior to the you
know antiretroviral therapy so therefore
we encouraging more research to be done
in the current generation of how do we
help change behavior when people have
treatment optimism because there is
treatment optimism now but we need to
think about well how how do we adjust
for that how do we make sure that
interventions address that issue and our
efficacious now the issue of getting
physicians to deliver an intervention
when we talked in with two physicians
frequently you know about putting in a
four minute message into their care when
they're treating a patient one physician
told me she said I work for a health
maintenance organization we're told we
have seven minutes per patient she said
so when you tell me I'm supposed to give
a four-minute message that only gives me
three minutes to diagnose and treat the
patient she said that's impossible
is the other thing you don't realize is
is that alcoholism groups are telling me
that I need to screen for alcoholism
with each of my patients the
anti-smoking people are telling me to
tell my patients to quit smoking that
they found out that five percent of
smokers will quick when their physician
tells them to quit and she says how can
I tell people to quit quit quit smoking
quit drinking and use a condom and also
be able to treat the patient at the same
time so we hear that from physicians and
I think that we really have to think
about several things one of the things
we have to think about is how to think
about the clinic as an organic
organization and who in the clinic can
deliver messages at what time during the
treatment process so that we are able to
get messages to patients in the clinic
experience I think by having Loretta
jamaat's work with nurses helps give us
more evidence that interventions can be
delivered by a healthcare team and I
think so those are some of the things we
have to think about the other thing is
is that physicians tell tell us they
cannot come to a Debbie training they
say you're Debbie trainings are three
four and five days we can't do it we
can't do that so that's led us to begin
experimenting now with thinking about
how would we do distance learning
particularly for nurses and for
physicians who cannot take three four or
five days off the job to learn a
behavioral intervention so thank you for
those questions Thank You Charles I
think we need to move on to our next
speaker and that will be very callous
Barry is the head of the hiv/aids
prevention and education unit at the
State Department of Health and the state
of Massachusetts my home state and I was
just reading an article about
Massachusetts health plan and I was
wondering why I came to Connecticut left
that's visits kinetic Massachusetts has
done other progressive work as well
around hiv/aids programming and berries
office as has adapted several Debbie's
but also has encouraged a lot of
homegrown interventions and in been
involved in the replication of some of
the Debbie so I with would like to
welcome Barry thank you
hi and good afternoon how is everyone
good good ok I'm going to test my
computer skills here
the redbox off sorry thank you very much
okay just close it up thank you very
much here I am okay so I'm very callous
I oversee the prevention and education
unit thank you very much in the office
of AIDS in the Bureau of infectious
disease and I'm going to be talking
today specifically from a health
department perspective in supporting
staff in agencies in supporting
organizations to implement these science
based interventions in a way that's
manageable okay and just for everyone's
orientation purposes the role of the
state health department is to plan and
respond to the prevention needs of those
likely to become infected are those
individuals living with HIV and in
Massachusetts we have just a we have 56
funded programs across the state that
serve gay men that serve injection drug
users that serve women transgenders and
ID use and refugee refugee and immigrant
populations the other piece of work that
I oversee includes community planning
new pilot initiatives and adding to the
field adding to the intervention field
that Charles referenced we like to
consider ourselves supporting
community-based agencies who have
interventions to take those
interventions and to develop them
further for replication and hopefully
future Debbie interventions I'm going to
talk about our bureau goals some guiding
principles that guide our work I'm going
to give some history and background of
some work that we did during 2002 and
2003 to assess the impact of our
prevention work statewide i'm going to
give some an overview of the steps of
implementation
what we did to implement these
evidence-based interventions I'm going
to talk about the things that we do to
support local intervention development I
want to highlight some of the successes
and challenges that we've had because we
certainly have had many of them there
have been lots of things that we didn't
anticipate that we had to resolve all
organized ourselves around so I'm
hopefully I'll be able to highlight some
of those points that will be helpful to
everyone and I have some recommendations
to close my presentation just to start
the goals of the office of hiv/aids to
increase the number of individuals who
know their HIV status to reduce the
number of new HIV infections and into
and to improve the health and well-being
of persons living with and at risk for
HIV so whether it's client service work
prevention work health service work all
of our work in the office of AIDS is
organized around the achieva least three
Bureau goals we have a set of principles
that guide all of our work and these
principles include a commitment to
equitable access to prevention and care
services a commitment to personal
autonomy and preservation of civil
rights and civil liberties a commitment
to strict strict observance of
confidentiality of personal information
a commitment to maximizing the public
investment through smart linkage to
other pay sources we we know and I know
that this state knows all too well the
impact of the economy and how that's
impacting our publicly funded
programming and we have a commitment to
reducing health disparities in improving
the health status of all massachusetts
residents and for the office of aids
that includes gay and bisexual men
refugee and immigrant communities and
racial and ethnic minority populations a
little bit of history and context of
what led us to require all of our
prevention programs to implement an
evidence-based intervention is that we
had effective programs that were born
out of responding to the initial crisis
and we're very effective
and were making monumental changes with
reducing new infections and getting
folks into care we wanted to move
towards more longer range prevention
programming we were also experiencing a
real uneven experience we were really
experiencing a lot of uneven performance
among a number of our programs some of
the interventions that they were
implementing we're a bit outdated didn't
really match the needs or the stated
needs of populations we took about a
year prior to the release of a
procurement to do some assessment of
available research to look at the impact
of our current programming and to look
at the data from that programming we
wanted to increase the evidence-based of
our programming and we wanted to make
sure that we were doing the most
effective work possible this also
coincided so our this internal review
that we were doing also coincided with
the Debbie intervention process so we
thought it was a great opportunity to
use the resources and work that CDC had
done around packaging and testing some
of these interventions and to implement
them locally in making this change from
initial crisis response to prevention
and information around HIV we knew that
we had some work to do to ready our
system for this new set of strategies
that we wanted to support so in addition
to reviewing the research and data from
our programs we had a series of what of
what we call public engagement sessions
these sessions went beyond the general
public but were very specifically
targeted to gay men to transgenders to
injection drug users folks and recovery
and youth and young adults we organized
sessions across the state to hear from
folks directly what were their needs
around prevention what kind of models
would fit your community we wanted to be
responsive to the various of nuances in
each one of the regions of our state and
there are five of those
how many folks here know about community
planning or may currently be
participating or have participated in
community planning through show of hands
wow that's great ok so in Massachusetts
we have one Community Planning Group
it's the Massachusetts HIV prevention
community planning group they advise us
on effective interventions and
populations that need to be reached with
those interventions and increasingly
really guiding us around policy we took
their recommendations the Community
Planning Group recommendations into this
analysis we also hosted a series of
Institute's for our existing provider
system and those providers who expressed
interest in becoming a provider so we
hosted a number of Institute's that did
very much the very that were very
similar to Charles's presentation we
went through the available interventions
we had the original research is
available to talk about the populations
and some of the implementation
strategies that folks were going to need
so we did a lot of training capacity
building readying folks already existing
and potential applicants to this new
method of doing work as a result of the
Institute as a institutes as a result of
doing the capacity building as a result
of the engagement sessions and as a
result of looking at the program data
and what we thought was effective in
those things that we wanted to correct
we established a new service standards
we establish some new standards around
staff qualifications and record and we
requirement in a requirement for all of
our programs that we funded in the
future to have an evidence-based element
to their program it's important to note
that the Debbie intervention is not the
sole intervention that makes up a
prevention program that's really
important to us we recognize the value
of the Debbie's but we also know there
has to be an extensive amount of basic
education to the population of a range
of clients client recruitment activities
a range of materials distribution
activities all those things together
with the Debbie
make up a prevention program not the
debbie in and of itself one of the next
highlights some of our local steps for
implementation we hosted and attended
local and national Debbie trainings we
were fortunate enough to have enough
individuals to fill a 25-person plus
training so in those cases we worked
with the CDC capacity building provider
to come and do trainings for
Massachusetts providers in those cases
where we couldn't fill a training or
where the resources were stretched we
actually sent our staff including health
department staff and provider staff to
some of those national trainings this
was all happening at the time of trying
to start up our direct programming so we
had to be very flexible with the time
frames when our programs were to start
and when folks had the necessary
training to implement those
interventions we also learned it was
important to provide training on the
content as the CDC trainings were
happening we found it very important to
give feedback on some of the currency of
some of that training content to make it
more current and to make sure that the
current standards of practice that we
had as a state were reinforced in those
trainings it was really important for us
to participate in them at the close of
the vast majority of the initial
trainings we assess the implementers
needs and by implementers I mean the
staff of our funded organizations we
recognized that the initial training and
the tools that come with that training
to help implement these interventions
certainly were good initial tools to
begin to implement but we knew that
folks needed more so as a result we
piloted a number of what we call
technical assistance sessions so we
brought together all of the individuals
that were implementing empowerment and
what we did is we had one in two days
sessions where we
work with those folks to make sure that
the core elements of those interventions
and the barriers that they may have
experienced or may be facing or
addressed so that could proceed with
implementing those interventions
successfully we also in addition to
implementing the Debbie interventions we
like to make sure that we're supporting
local interventions that are that were
born out of the community-based agencies
and the populations themselves that have
shown effectiveness to work so in our
procurement not only could you select to
implement one of the Debbie
interventions but you could also select
to implement your homegrown intervention
as long as it had a theory basis behind
it in in a lot of cases some of those
interventions focused on emerging
population needs or where interventions
were limited and I know that we had
several interventions that we're working
with women of color because at the time
they weren't were not enough
interventions for women of color we had
some of those interventions that we
supported that we're not Debbie's that
were targeted to gay and bisexual men as
well as sub-saharan sub-saharan African
populations in a lot of our formalized
venues that we have so whether it's a
conference or whether we're doing
technical assistance of training
sessions we in an ongoing way solicit
ideas from our programs or from
colleagues or from researchers locally
on promising models we want to be sure
that we take the best idea as possible
that are coming from the community and
work with those models to formalize them
a bit more for replication and four and
four possible dissemination we've built
in sustained a number of partnerships
locally with schools of Social Work
schools of Nursing and public health
with researches and interested
individuals in those institutions who
have worked with us to take some of
those interventions and prepare them
ready for packaging and descent
and replication we also with these with
those interventions we want to be sure
that we're presenting initial findings
on those interventions at conferences
and we're eagerly looking forward to
replicating those interventions when the
opportunity is available expanding
programming options again we do a lot of
work to seed intervention development we
participate in replication studies we
participated in boces voices we
participated in healthy relationships we
think that's a really good idea and way
to be part of the research project
process to help shape the final product
we have recently conducted some
formative planning for hiv-positive
individuals and refugee and immigrant
populations to aid in intervention
development and I can't underscore
enough the importance of maintaining
local partnership for replication
studies lessons learned commitment from
partners is critical commitment from
nonprofit organizations from staff and
communities are critical to implement
these interventions some of these
interventions are very complicated some
of them not don't always work in this in
the real world setting but
implementation and success as possible
sustained technical assistance is
essential so beyond the training ta is
needed we've been very creative in
sharing resources whether that's
bartering exchanges between research
institutions training vendors and the
Health Department we encourage
adaptation when it's indicated currency
is essential and it's really important
to invest in ongoing workforce
development helping those implement is
continually develop skills to implement
these interventions with accuracy and
fidelity among our successes we have a
variety of evidence-based interventions
that are implemented locally we've
experiment the experience with these
interventions have
done these over the last four to five
years we have seen the evidence of value
to community and clients and these
interventions have been very important
bridges to comprehensive infectious
disease prevention screening and
referral services in terms of
recommendations that I would have we
really believe that interventions need
to be increased that meet comprehensive
sexual health compulsive behavior and
infectious disease prevention screening
and support goals these interventions of
certainly are an important goal into
meeting whole person needs and we want
to support the comprehensive nature of
future interventions increasing the
availability of these interventions that
integrate priority health concerns and
life circumstances and I was delighted
to see some of the among the eight newly
publicized debri interventions
incarceration and individuals who have
experienced trauma there are
interventions that are specifically
geared to individuals with those life
circumstances we have some quality
assurance procedures in place I'd like
to see more particularly in the area of
individual and group education we are
revising our data collection tool for
prevention services we hope to have that
done in the next year and again
sustaining collaborations with
community-based agencies and researchers
I'm seeing that I have one minute so I'm
going to skip this and I will want to
make sure that this presentation is
available to the organizers and thank
you very much for your time and
attention
we have a few minutes for questions if
there are any yes other Debbie's for
heterosexual men yes there are and we
also have non Debbie interventions that
will look that we're implementing
locally for heterosexual men now maybe
Charles would you like to highlight some
of those interventions for heterosexual
men voices is our primary 144
heterosexual men but we are not next
year but by the but within probably
about 18 months we're also going to be
diffusing another one for heterosexual
men call Nia African American is really
designed for African American
heterosexual men yes
we are delighted and happy to share any
of these interventions that you're
interested in we have one for
sub-saharan Africans we have one for
hiv-positive african-american women that
are 40 and over we have a safety net so
we have a number of interventions that
were more than happy to share with you
sure thing absolutely other comments or
questions yes
mmm yeah
I
mm-hmm
okay thanks for your comment in
questions we think it's absolutely
critical to be sure that we currently
that we continually solicit ideas and
take non debbie interventions from the
field whether we're funding the program
or not and develop that as much as
possible to ready those interventions
for for the study of effectiveness and
for possible future replication so we're
lucky enough in Massachusetts to have a
number of universities and colleges we
have we have ongoing relationships with
researchers for other projects and we're
always looking to build our connections
with them around taking some of these
interventions and readying them enough
to become a Debbie intervention if I
overlook some of your question help me
out we in many cases these researchers
are applied researches so they're
working you know in the cases where
we've taken these interventions and
readying them for a Debbie possible
Debbie implementation these researchers
are already in the field working with
the populations and are doing other
related research and so it's an
outgrowth of current work that they're
doing so we're lucky enough to have
enough individuals locally to take these
ideas and mature them and run with them
and develop them we also have had a
great advocate and colleague with
Charles being at the CDC he's heard from
us on a number of occasions with some
interventions that were really excited
about and we've worked with him around
with him and linking him to the
researcher so that there can be a
clearly understood and coordinated path
to development so did that answer all of
your okay thanks
okay thanks very much everyone okay our
next speaker is sariah elcock and Soraya
is the deputy director for policy and
government relations at Harlem United
Community Aid Center in Manhattan or in
New York City sorry and she is going to
talk with us about the experience the
authentic experience of adapting
evidence-based interventions at the
community level but before soria comes
up to the microphone i have to say that
i am both very pleased that she's here
and relieved because up until the
eleventh hour we weren't sure if she was
going to be able to wrestle herself away
from the new york state legislature
where she was warding off some
apparently regressive legislation on HIV
testing and you know such as the reality
of people who work on the policy end of
things but sirois has a long record and
if you look at her biosketch of working
as an advocate and activist in
communities of color on issues of HIV
that go back to nineteen ninety-two has
held multiple positions including
running about 11 different programs and
i think and tell the story of working
before you had evidence base and you
know and then and then making that
transition so welcome sir Roy
thank you so much Elaine um okay so I
need to make two confessions first of
all arm 1 i'm going to have to read and
hit the button and speak simultaneously
so it might be a little bit ugly and two
I really want to while I thank i'm alane
and the group for inviting me here and i
really am excited to be here i do want
to do what my nephew would call a shout
out because you were talking about the
difficulty in getting me here was
supposed to be in DC so they booked me
from DC then I was like oh no I have to
be in albany no i think and can go back
to DC so Sandrine I think booked me
about six different places and when she
met me here she didn't spit in my face
so thank her and thank you for all of
that word so okay let me first find me
he said just hit the button go to the X
right I heard my colleague in the room
say hit the red X hit the button my god
okay and I just hit and do this how do I
move forward
you're all a frightened aren't you and I
can't tell you how much of your tax
dollars I get to play with every day
okay okay so and just now I go Eric Tara
hi um so yeah my name is sariah alcock
and I am currently we actually just went
through title changes in the
organization for the executive team so
they now call me the vice president for
policy and government relations and my
salary did increase at all and my
mortgage company neither my partner
cares what my title is but we now are
called vice president the first slide
really just show the scope and the
breadth of the work or what the
organization currently looks like today
you've got the three circles and they're
all interlocked because what that really
does is demonstrate one of the guiding
principles about the organization so H
health care prevention and housing of
the core areas of the organization but
unless we integrate the work within all
of those three divisions the agency
itself doesn't work we've actually had a
really interesting development Harlem
United was founded around 1988 at the
height of the hiv/aids epidemic and I
love how we got founded we're in Harlem
which unfortunately back then and even
today is talked about and considered the
epicenter of the epidemic in New York
City and what we were facing was an
epidemic that nobody really understood
and people were running down what we
call downtown below 125 street to get
services so we were founded by actually
two gay men women religious and some
priests because folks were running
around going what is this what can I do
when a gay hiv-positive man reached out
to his pastor and said I need help
specifically we were designed to really
serve folks who had suffering from
homelessness mental health and substance
use issues and pretty much today
that is pretty it still continues to be
some of the issues that the kinds that
we deal with are struggling with
consider the agency of last resort for
the medically underserved in Harlem when
we started the agency we were in the
basement of st. Phyllis st. Philip's I
think it's called church back in 1988
the running joke is that the arm
counseling room was actually the men's
gym and actually still smelt like the
mainstream but that was the way we
actually began because we just had to
step out to do the work we were founded
to address the lack of response from
more established providers because the
folks that we dealt with the folks that
we continue to serve our what folks talk
about is the heart to reach once you
reach them they're hard to engage once
you've engaged them they're hard to keep
in care because of all of those
multiplicity of issues so from 1998 to
about 96 really small para professional
organization we had a couple of units of
housing programs and we had what we call
social day care because what we were
trying to do is since so many of our
clients were struggling with substance
use recreated that safe space so that
folks would let's say use all day you
got to harlem united we were called the
upper room aids ministry at the st.
Phyllis basement you were able to get a
hot meal a sense of community and some
counseling but in 1993 the board of
Harlem United was pretty ballsy can I
say ballsy I can take Baltic um that's
pretty ballsy and we got license to
create what we call an adult day health
care center there about eight of them
that exists and it's a model that only
exists in New York State and everybody
looked at this crazy little tiny
mom-and-pop organization in a basement
and said you're going to do a license
program but what is always driven Harlem
United is first and foremost if it's
needed we've got to find a way to create
it because as I said before folks didn't
have the capacity or actually want
to deal with the folks that we saw in
our organization it was actually a bold
move to create an Adult Day Health Care
Center to get a license for it and a lot
of more established organizations we're
a little risk observed because it's a
really risky model Medicaid driven the
risk are incredible but it was clearly
what was needed at the time it was also
really visionary because in 1996 the
advent of hiv/aids therapies hit and
what we were able to do then is create
in a grassroots community based
organization health care for those
individuals we serve I mentioned before
that we were called the upper room aids
ministry and in 1995 we changed our name
to Harlem United community center
because everybody thought we were
somehow I am a religious organization
and not that there's anything wrong with
religion heathen that I am but we wanted
to make sure that there was a name that
was more reflective of the organization
and the reason we were originally called
the upper room I said before we were
founded by ministers and women religious
and where the organization met was in
the upper room the top room of a liquor
store and there is a part in the Bible
that talks about Jesus lifting people
from the upper room where you gave
people from turning fair into hope so in
this upper room what these folks were
doing for people in Harlem living with
hiv/aids was trying to create programs
and services that would turn fair into
hope so we changed our name but kept
that same mission around fear into hope
the Adult Day Health Care Center the ad
8c really kicked us and gave us the
ability to seize upon medical advances
so we were the first Adult Day Health
Care Center to really add primary
medical care I think we did it around
2000 we did direct observe observed
therapy and that's not just around HIV 8
meds but that was also around mental
health meds from school that our clients
are struggling with we're a founding
member of either care which is a special
each plan for people living with
hiv/aids and in 07 we opened the Spanish
language was the first and only
bilingual adult day health care center
in the country where people of Spanish
descent are able to benefit from an
adult day health care center and then we
got a federally qualified health care
center in about 20 7 we were designated
as a federally federally qualified
health care center for the homeless okay
here's the part that I love the best I
mean it's all great but i got to harlem
united in 1999 and i got there as the
director of the prevention education &
policy division which is what prevention
at harlem united was called at the time
and the reason I went to Harlem United
was in the past I did policy work I was
at a place called Federation of products
and welfare agencies and my job was to
do HIV AIDS policy for African American
and Latino women and children a lot of
stuff around permanency planning the
early years of the epidemic and what I
was missing was kind of the program the
folks the people so i could do policy i
could do analysis but i wanted to get
with the folks who i was writing these
policies for or doing this advocacy for
so I went up to Harlem united in 1999
and my job my mission was to grow our
prevention division at the time we had
two small contracts and I left harm the
prevention division because it got too
large and the policy got so large in
2007 and focused just on policy where we
had 14 programs now I don't tell you
that to to brag I was actually in the
right place at the right time because in
1999 the minority aids initiative had
hit and we wrote seven you know our
proposals hoping to get to and we got
seven and I was too dumb and young to
realize no sane person starts seven
programs at want right I thought if you
build it they will come if it's based on
research and data of course they go
to your crow ground yeah short bald and
insane um but back then one of the
things that was really something about
the organization that really appealed to
me was there was always an emphasis on
where do we need to go next so even
before CDC talked about advancing eight
strategies and hiv/aids counseling and
prevention for positive by the nature of
being in the work you could see that's
what we needed to do you could see
that's where we needed to go so the
prevention division started doing that
we one of the first organization that
make sure everybody became a certified
pre and post-test counselor we built in
interventions pulling on the Debbie
programs because we wanted to have the
ability to actually create or pilot what
we thought was necessary and I think the
biggest most exciting thing we've done
recently is in 2007 we married an
organization called frosted which had
been established back in the 80s and it
focused on hiv/aids and um what are they
called when you sell it for money sex
workers ooh I need a nap um and and what
we've the reason we married frosted
frosted had a syringe exchange license
right they function downtown and buy
2005 2006 we're sitting going how do you
do mobile HIV testing without doing Hep
C screening and syringe exchange all in
one van because some of the funniest
things is to go uptown in Harlem and or
most neighborhoods and you'll see the
syringe exchange van lined up behind the
HIV testing van lined up behind the Hep
C screening van and what we didn't want
to do was have to go through the
community board to get a syringe
exchange license I'm just way too old
for that kind of ugly fight and frosted
needed a partner because it needed
evaluation and research so it was a
great marriage so what do we have now
this is pretty much what the prevention
division looks like and I'm going to
focus when we look at research and
intervention
on the testing Department and education
and training department our frosted at
Harlem United is really where our health
care prevention services for injection
drug users live and in education and
training that's where some elbow
behavioral interventions live along with
some of the Debbie's that we do and in
testing we look at different testing
strategies and one of our homegrown HIV
testing strategy program live in testing
let me just make sure I've told you
everything that I wrote on my paper to
tell you okay so inches I put this slide
up because it's really important I think
it's the reason we are able to do
evaluation and do some of the research
that we do in 2003 2000 between two or
three and 0 5 we made a significant
investment in evaluation and research
right not because CDC was saying we need
to have evaluation you have to data if
you're directly doing the work I know a
lot of times you get the money you
implement the program and you have if
you're lucky because when we were small
we didn't have the evaluation capacity
but you did your basic pre and post-test
survey but there's nothing more painful
than spending my mother likes to call it
her tax dollars for three years on an
intervention where you want to make the
difference in somebody's life to find
out after three years you didn't and
what we wanted to do was have the
ability as we went along implementing
creating and operating these programs
how do i need to change it how do i need
to fix it what is this data telling me
what's working and what's not working so
in oh 3 and 0 5 my ed and I said we got
to make the investment and so within
each of those three areas prevention
health care and housing we everybody has
evaluation staff the evaluation model
that we use our is really a management
model and we call it the triad because
it has three parts i actually call it
father patch holy trinity because my
executive director
was an ex-priest and this is his Bible
this is as Holy Trinity this is how we
manage programs we evaluate programs and
we're able to create other programs
based on using the triad the three
components and tell me if I'm going to
quickly good because you're probably all
napping right um cqi our valuation model
one of the guiding principles that we
manage programs by we don't even call it
evaluation model as much as we call it
the management model every program
within the agency so when I showed you
all of those programs on the first slide
every single one of those programs
whether you're in healthcare housing or
prevention use the triad every staff is
involved with the triad so continuous
quality improvement really focus on the
program's performance but what we do is
from the outreach worker to the program
director all of those people create the
indicators that they're going to review
and once a month you pull charts
randomly and everybody reviews them we
don't focus on who the person is who did
that deliverable or didn't do it it's
about assessing the program as a whole
in our data driven administrative
supervision the focus is on the
individual performer I'm not reviewing
it for did you do it well or did you not
do it well I'm reviewing it for did you
do it did the assessment happen did the
reassessment happen then you link the
client to care it's an individual
performance and then the third arm of
the triad is our clinical supervision
which is really all about building and
developing clinical skills so usually
the way it works is the data-driven
supervisor would refer that particular
staff to the clinical director because
there's some clinical work that the
person needs to develop in order to do
his or her work better which comes back
to make sure then the program when you
look at continuous quality improvement
if those two arms are working you'll see
the benefit in your cpy when you review
charts so as I said our evaluation it's
not just about the program that you're
currently looking at but it's also the
ability to create better program models
and within the three division we've seen
some of those take place in prevention
we actually which is one of the things I
was going to show you based on our
evaluation of some of our programs
created a risk-based and geographic base
HIV testing and was able to compare the
two to see where do I get better
outcomes where's my sero positivity rate
better in terms of risk base and in
terms of geographic base in healthcare
we were able to create what we call the
full service medical home we did a
little program a survey that focused on
the issue of aging which allowed us to
provide primary medical care that
surpassed 16 of the National hip cual
indicators and the reason I talk about
it that way it's because that's
important for staff to understand they
need to benchmark their work against
something they need to feel that I'm a
grassroots community based organization
but that doesn't mean data is not
important to me they get to see how data
and research gets translated from that
guy or that girl in the white coat how
you can translate that stuff how you can
use your own evaluation tools and
directly see the impact and the change
in your client life that you get to
drive and in housing it was really
exciting for us because we have about
500 units of supportive housing and you
have a housing contract every house and
client gets treated the same I do X
number of home visits for all 700 people
and at some point housing staff said but
wait a minute Soraya's been with us for
10 years knock wood she's healthy I go
to see her she's taking her medication
she talks to me about her issues with
her children her psychosocial why am I
going to see Soraya every week as a
manufactures got a part-time job but
over here Sonja was also been with us
for 10 years failing on our treatment
still struggling with substance use her
partner's still kicking
but I want to be able to go see Sonja
twice a week and maybe see Soraya once a
month and through testing that piloting
that with our evaluation we were able to
get our funders to let us do that they
didn't change the scatter site housing
model program for the whole city but we
had day they enough for them to say okay
go ahead pilot it let me see what kind
of outcomes health outcomes you get when
you focus on the critical clients based
on what you see in their charts in terms
of their health care okay so a couple of
examples of how we took research into
practice to serve people with hiv/aids
in Harlem now we talked a lot about this
because I do a presentation in New York
City for our arm prevention planning
group that I was the co-chair of and at
this point you talk about it and people
go wow now let me tell you it wasn't
pretty okay taking research into your
community based organization is a
cultural shift this looks all pretty on
paper took us a year and a half for
folks to really get understand first the
Triad and that get understand why the
research is important why are we going
to take these Debbie things and practice
them because we know there's a historic
distrust of researchers and folks who do
the word and unless we start having
those hard conversations then we don't
really bridge that gap and
community-based organizations don't get
to see the benefits of research
researchers don't get to really
experience which is a powerful
experience what it's like to do research
at that level living with those people
hearing from those people and being able
to take their day-to-day experience
maybe going back and tweaking your tool
tweaking your document based on what's
really out there so it sounds pretty it
wasn't pretty it was a long gruesome
process and it really was about doing a
whole cultural shift within your
organization and I think it's a
if that still has to continue I did a
presentation about the importance of arm
research about six months ago and
actually had a colleague in another
organization say to me Oh God Soraya you
know you're so good you're so smart I
can't believe you bought into the white
man's model and I was like what did I
miss what am I talking what did I say
and in her head any type of evaluation
is a Eurocentric philosophy process that
doesn't really speak to how we should do
the work and what's happening and after
drilling down and having a conversation
with her i said you know here's what it
is it's the early 80s folks are dying we
don't know what's going on and everybody
rolled up your sleeve and you jumped in
and you just did what you needed to do
right back then you didn't know what the
H meant with the I met what the vmail
right but you know people were sick
people were dying advocacy grew up a
real strong commitment to community
advocacy grew up because remember we had
a president who could even say HIV for
five years so I get that sense of
mistrust but there's a thing my
grandmother always says when you know
better you do better and in 2009 we know
better in 2009 we have research we can
do research we have to have the
conversations let's say the epidemic
doesn't look the same as it did in the
80s and I see she's writing on her pet
so I'm speeding up so um I want to talk
about to debbie's that we've taken a
look at healthy relationships and
adapting it for african-american msms
popular opinion leaders that we adapted
for african-american MSM someone talked
about not having enough MSM Debbie's and
I know more and more coming back in the
way the day in 2004 when we were started
this there was only many men many voices
and if you look at the data there is no
way you can't see that there's a big
need for more interventions for MSM and
especially in Harlem historically we
serve a lot of african-american latino
men who have sex with men and they're a
huge part of our population and there is
a huge part of the community
Eastern Central Harlem although they way
underground and you'll see when I talk
about pol what we did was adapted and
found out the venue that worked for us
was the internet and then I'm just going
to do briefly talk about social networks
for african-american women and MSM I
know y'all think we're a little MSM
photograph a little obsessive okay and
some day that we got from that and then
the one that I'm really excited about
blocks which is a program we got a
little bit of money to do from the MAC
AIDS Fund to pilot it got some really
interesting data which i apologize i
don't have for you today because the
evaluator wasn't able to get it to me
because you didn't know if i was in DC
here in Albany and it really focuses on
zone based testing versus risk based
testing so jobs did a great job of
telling you about popular opinion leader
it's a community level intervention that
really focuses on identify key
stakeholders and the influencers in the
community right these are people who
have the ability to influence community
norms in their particular neighborhood
the justification for that formative
evaluation I the reason we adapted it
for the Internet is because the
formative evaluation that we did show
that that was the most effective way to
reach young msms right so everybody
knows that the the issue around em SMS
and hiv/aids changes like everything
else and has been changing for years and
in the early years of the epidemic in
Harlem you knew where the sex clubs were
right so we had all different
interventions that we try you go into
the sex clubs arm what's happening now
is that stuff has moved more and more
and more and more underground right so
the hot spots the zones where m sms are
kicking it changes every 20 minutes what
we realize too after doing some research
was a lot of that stuff now is happening
on the internet right our earlier
speaker talked about the power of the
Internet to misinform well the power of
the Internet
there's about 3,000 websites I don't
even know the technology but we have
connections to them all where that's
where young guys are now cruising for
sex and so we adapted pol for the
internet the objective there was to
provide messages and conversations to
promote savor sex behaviors when you
looked and we did some of our evaluation
work a lot of [ __ ] is going on a
lot of young men think somebody earlier
talked about um treatment people
thinking treatment is here so I don't
need to do the same level of HIV
prevention i think the scariest
statement i ever heard what i was part
of some of the formative research on
this and the the 17 year old who said to
me I'll soraya I get it I understand but
you don't get it if not if when I get
HIV I'm just going to take the pills now
this was only about two years ago so
it's not like oh my god two years ago
when I get HIV I'm just going to take
the meds and then I'll be fine and on
another note which is another
conversation the other piece I hear all
the time from folks is because you can
get services that way right we've
created a whole system of care which we
should for people living with hiv/aids
but sometimes when you do the work in
Harlem we have a federally qualified
health center to target homeless people
so they don't have to be HIV positive
but they have the same issues that
Soraya has who's positive so Soraya's
black she's 30 years old she's poor
she's under educated she's positive
she's gotten her behind beaten for the
last 20 years all of those psychosocial
issues that we know drive the epidemic
and here Sheila black mother 30 should
look exactly like Soraya except Sheila
is not HIV positive and I don't have a
system of care for Sheila so when Sheila
says to me damn it looks like a little
HIV is my best way to get some housing
the back of your neck should be freaked
out which it is but those are some of
the issues when you look at the dynamic
in Harlem just quickly this is a
snapshot of our pol training you can
just see pre the training and post the
training people's knowledge
went up Debbie and I'm doing this
quickly because I really want to get to
the other one so the other debut that we
looked at was healthy relationships and
we did this intervention for
hiv-positive men and women we looked at
it for MSM small group intervention
today the 103 m sms have gone through
this intervention now here's what's
really interesting here's what I love
this was a failure for us a failure in
terms of the fidelity that you need to
truly adapt bubs we didn't figure it out
it didn't work whatever you want to call
it but the beauty for me was working
with the CDC to take what we had done to
almost model what adaptation should look
like so one of the hardest things when
your community based organization and
you're trying to adapt something you're
all of the key elements you have to eat
for it to be evident based on it to be
true and that's important to me but what
do you do when you screw up somewhere
but you already have 60 people in some
kind of intervention you started doing
something you messed up somewhere
somebody dropped the ball what does it
mean well see this he was able to come
in and take what we did and helped us
come up with an adaptation of an
adaptation so you know they're critical
things you can't do their critical Jews
that are elements of the program but if
if you did something they call it red
light green light if you did something
that was different one of the elements
is three sessions but based on the folks
you're dealing with they said oh I need
a whole other session to help me
maintain this behavior so you put
another session in right green light
it's still evidence-based but what
happened when that person says no a
workshop doesn't work it needs to be a I
don't know a community level
intervention instead of putting six
folks into the workshop we need to make
this a dirty person that means I screwed
up that means I don't get to continue
the work they call that red light so
you're not really still
to the Debbie criteria but you're still
doing something and how do you then come
in and evaluate that and model that so
you can have some outcomes that can help
you possibly build something else and we
use our triad to help us work that in
the CDC came in to give us the ability
to do that so you're still doing
something that's evidence-based even
though it doesn't follow the exact
adaptation that you had started to do um
so just some preliminary results of our
adaptation 44 m sms that we were trying
to do so you see the thirty-six percent
pre-implementation post-implementation
it went to 40 and then this one is about
how do I inform my male partners about
my status and the thing about these
interventions is how do you do the
follow-up the follow-up is what's really
not exciting to me but really important
to me because while you have somebody in
your intervention and then a couple
months after your intervention a week I
think it's right there it's easier to
hold onto especially at a Harlem United
we're able to pull folks into other
pieces of the agency right so you're in
prevention you're doing this I don't
want to lose you I put you in my food
and nutrition program so I can hold on
to you and give you a safe space but
what I want to make sure that six months
from now you can still absorb use and
your life is moved by intervention and
we can see some of the results there so
this one I find really interesting this
is a risk-based approach around your
social networking so on the top what is
that the left-hand side that represents
the initial recruiter that we got from
social networking like the
social-networking says you're not going
out to find me strangers to bring in for
HIV testing you're bringing me your
friends your lover's right you bring me
the people that are really closest to
you so that recruiter went out and we
initiated him as a recruiter he
identified whatever the number is six
HIV
positive individuals he intend in turn
recruited another recruiter here who
identified 10 individuals but they're
all if it's not darkly colored in that
means those individuals he identified
were not HIV positive so over here my
original recruiter from his social
network found one two three four five
hiv-positive people from that was able
to find another recruiter who identified
folks from his social network although
they were not positive at the time and
that's how it continues and grows and
grows and grows because it's the social
networking that we realize we need to
infiltrate we did I'm high-risk clients
tested through social network had a
positivity rate of 6.3 for women and
14.6 for men social networking is one of
the strongest strongest interventions in
identifying new HIV positive individuals
um so zone based approach which is
really what we call blocks we took a
look about a year ago we got a little
bit of money to pilot what we call
blocks and blocks is really an approach
to testing that's geographic I don't
want to say vs but compared to risk
based testing because more and more when
you look at the epidemic HIVs as much
about who you are is where you live
right in Harlem you're talking about
high prevalence high incidence you're
talking about social networking chances
are you going to run up against some HIV
so what we wanted to do an in Harlem
people aren't assessing themselves at
risk so what we wanted to do because we
had these high numbers were say well
rather than just doing risk base let's
identify zones let's identify the hot
spots using peers using influencers tell
me where they're doing the do and what
we did was take a 20-block radius and we
did an entire intervention called block
so for six months I am in that 20 blocks
where it is I'm working with the
churches the
Oh drugstore the supermarket and I'm
going door by door block by block to
educate and offer HIV testing versus
identifying that person risk and
bringing them in for HIV testing I have
a minute so I'm just going to jump to
conclusion to show you all strategies of
these different testing risk-based
social network zone they work they work
for different populations however what
we've seen is that Geographic approach
is responsible for the larger proportion
of the total hiv-positive people
identify especially when you are in an
area or I think the way the epidemic is
today many people always telling me
they're not at risk I'm not at risk I'm
not at risk a lot of people are testing
late twenty-eight percent of the folks
in Harlem testing for HIV are finding
out they have AIDS at the point of
testing HIV because they were their
assessment was they were never at risk
but what I'm able to do with a
geographic based approach is reach those
people offer them HIV testing so that
they can no earlier get on treatment
earlier save their lives reduce the
community viral load in their community
it's actually another interesting thing
about this is it's helping us to really
create our policy position around HIV
testing there's nothing sexier to me
then when program research connect with
policy so that you can create something
that actually makes sense you'll still
have a fight because we're stuck with a
lot of policies that we created the
early years of the epidemic that people
haven't quite done a paradigm shift on
they can't let go of it and HIV testing
legislation is one of that it was a
reason I was having a hard time figuring
I was coming today because we're trying
to get legislation that relieves the
barriers of HIV testing the pretend
pretest counseling the pretend post-test
counseling and trying to get HIV testing
to be part of a routine health care so
that the doctor doesn't have to assess
the risk the client doesn't have to come
and say I'm at risk as part of my
routine health care when you look at the
epidemic of hiv/aids everybody gets
asked and everybody gets tested I'm
sorry I went so fast look my new titles
on the paper thank you so very much
take care hi questions okay thank you
all right thank you all and thank you
sir are for that great presentation I am
happy to introduce again Seth Kalesh man
who some of you heard this morning when
he spoke about AIDS denialism and he has
a new book that's coming out and he's
dedicating the proceeds so we encourage
you to buy that book and there are cards
i think around on the tables do we have
that yes there are any way Seth is going
to shift gears and talk about a
different subject seth has I'd mentioned
earlier as a professor in the Department
of Psychology at the University of
Connecticut and has done extensive HIV
prevention research as well as research
on HIV care he's going to talk today
about Debbie that he has been involved
in surveying community-based
organizations that are actually
implementing this Debbie so thank you
hey you learn a lot you know coming of
things like this I had fought that
Debbie actually stood for denying the
effectiveness of behavioral
interventions which is something that I
see policymakers engaging in a lot the
denial of effective behavioral
interventions recent I'm looking for
recently say well where'd you guys put
it
well let's try let's do it this way
let's try it this way there we go there
it is all right so um yeah I can talk to
you about a study that we did to look at
some of the technology transfer issues
around a particular Debbie called
healthy relationships how many you've
ever heard of healthy relationships they
were listening to you no no that's good
that's where they heard of it they
haven't come yet all right well then I
don't have to actually talk much so the
research that I present to you is
actually a product of our research group
called the share project which actually
exists in Atlanta Georgia and runs out
of the university Connecticut and it's
completely sponsored by the ni-mh by the
Nationalists FML now you know the early
days of HIV prevention were really
focused on delivering HIV prevention to
all people who might be at risk for
becoming infected and the CDC changed
course in 2003 really shifted prevention
priorities towards detection testing
people identifying infected people
getting them into treatment getting them
into care getting a min to prevention
services it's a totally different
approach it's called positive prevention
that's what i call it i like to call a
positive prevention and this particular
intervention falls into that approach
and so there's this whole process that
this intervention went through that i
had very little to do with you might
notice i like our marketing poster which
is basically popcorn movie theme that's
what we use in our research study to
market the intervention and email in
milwaukee and in atlanta but the people
that are in that picture actually we're
working milwaukee it's kind of weird but
the research was done in atlanta and
that's the image that the CDC uses to
market this intervention this debbie
called healthy
relationships I the intervention model
is really geared around social learning
theory a coping adaptation of social
learning theory social cognitive theory
it's a five session small group
intervention that's delivered by peer
and professional group facilitators the
intervention focuses on disclosure
decision-making skills and safer sex
negotiation skills it has a heavy
reliance on DVDs not video tapes anymore
stupid and movie clips for using movie
clips for popular films for doing the
skills training it's a highly
interactive group centered video based
skills building intervention we always
like to talk about it and these are the
core elements this is when Moses
descends from the mountain with the
tablets these are the core elements not
to be violated they despite their
arbitrary and sort of out of my hat
basis so healthy relationships define
stress and reinforces coping skills for
dealing with stressful situations it
uses behavioral rehearsal and Roll plays
to do focused feedback based coping
skills training it teaches
decision-making skills particularly
around HIV status disclosure it provides
personalized feedback reports this is a
core element to help motivate behavior
change and he uses movie clips to set up
scenarios for disclosure and Risk
Reduction role plays that's correct
right because I wouldn't know I pulled
them off your website all right okay
movie clips are really an important
feature of the intervention so when
people kind of have been trained in
healthy relationships that's kind of the
thing that they remember and know best
probably it's kind of a cool thing big
focus in the intervention is around
dealing with disclosure decision-making
skills which is kind of a stigma related
thing and the disclosure decision-making
skills move from family and friends and
other people in your lives to partners
these personalized feedback reports were
considered in port
when we did the research and and as and
as it turns out they might be a little
bit complicated to implement in practice
the skills building part is highly
interactive and so it involves kind of
hands-on literally saw skills training I
know that picture it's really late XO
you have to trust me it's really a
rubber penis and this is the package
it's like poof you know hocus pocus
these people at CDC and the people that
contract with they put all this crap
that we kind of just used and they make
it into a really nice thing I mean it's
like a really it's like a really cool
thing now we did not do the Debbie I
know you're going to think this is a
joke with people in Dallas to the Debbie
it's kind of like debbie does dallas
well Dallas did the Debbie and it
actually was it was actually produced by
the not the medial school the medical
school in south western Texas Medical
School in Dallas they did the Debbie Ann
Freeman's group really knows how to do
this stuff I don't and and for a better
or for worse and i think for better i
think they did a really great job
alright so what is the study that i want
to present to you today then said i want
to present to you today is a little
study we did over the summer last summer
to take a look at it maybe how agencies
are actually implementing this
particular debbie and it was kind of a
cool study for us to do because people
at the New York State Health Department
were interested in the answer and people
at CDC have been kind of interested in
the answer and I frankly had to have
something to talk about when people as
we talk about healthy relationships
because I haven't done anything with it
since 2001 so I had to come up with
something that I could present at a
conference like this so what we did was
we asked the CDC and we got no
resistance they were incredibly helpful
Charles cons you were great they sent us
the list of all of the agencies that
have been trained in healthy
relationships and so we had the universe
to sample and it was you know between
2005 when they started the training and
listen in this Debbie to April of 2008
there were 63 trainings that were
attended by just under a thousand people
909
nine people working within 235 asos and
cbos and 64 health departments that was
our universe that we were able to try to
contact all of those agencies and ask
them about their implementation with the
dev ease so with this Debbie so what we
did was we actually called them we tried
to connect with them we emailed and
called them and and that's how we did
this study so what we did what we were
able to do was try to sample not all
these agencies actually implement
Debbie's some of them are training and
some of them are like health departments
that oversee not everyone trained in
healthy relationships actually would be
an end user but really what we saw was
you know there were nine hundred ninety
nine total persons that were trained 299
agencies CBO's and health departments
that that were potential end users
although some of them we learned
actually would not be appropriate end
users we were unable to contact 139 of
them and we had people that were
scheduled but they were never completed
we found agencies that were out of
business some had refused a few had
didn't want to talk to us but we ended
up with a sample of a hundred and eleven
community-based organizations aids
service organizations and eleven health
departments that that did that were
appropriate and users for healthy
relationships and we completed in two
interviews with them of those 93 had
implemented healthy relationships and 29
did never implement it they were trained
but they didn't want to do it okay so
when we look at the not at the people
these agencies and again the agency is
really the unit here that we were
interested in when we look at the
agencies that um said they didn't
implement they were trained they were
interested but they didn't want to do it
the answers we asked them a number of
reasons why that might be and the top
three reasons seventy-four percent of
these 29 agencies that didn't implement
so that it that healthy relationships
did not meet their agency's needs and
priorities sixty-three percent said it
was too difficult to implement and
sixty-three percent said
they it didn't meet the community needs
and of course they could say more than
one thing obviously okay but the big
things here are just it wasn't a really
good fit and and and was too too
cumbersome to do and didn't meet our
agency's needs now we asked them about
the very specific activities in healthy
relationships that actually reflect the
core elements so these are the
activities that are the where the action
is in the core elements these are the
things that they're really supposed to
do to maintain fidelity to this
intervention and what we found actually
was a good number of agencies changed
the activities and a smaller number but
not insignificant drop the activities
all together now the way the healthy
relationships is structured is the same
activities are repeated three times the
repeated Ford disclosure decision making
to family and friends then there then
there those same activities are
basically reframed and done for
disclosure decision making to sex
partners and then for safer sex decision
making and what we see is for the family
and friends the pfr the personalized
feedback report the most likely to be
changed and dropped the decision grid
was changed so these are like core
element activities there's a lot of
adaptation going on and some dropping
and when we asked him why the most
common reason why is to make it fit the
community there's a theme emerging here
same thing with disclosure to sex
partners the pfr the personalized
feedback report which is a core element
is most likely to be dropped and very
likely to be changed the movie clips for
the skills training are also likely to
be trained changed and that isn't using
different movie clips it had to be the
way that they use them okay so they're
adapting the way that they use cuz
they're they can choose from a lot of
different movie clips that's not the
point it's how they use them in the same
thing for safer sex you know what we
have is agencies changing and dropping
the same activities across these domains
and for the same reasons to simplify or
two
prove the community fit when we took all
of those ratings of those different
factors and we put them into an analysis
to see which ones were the most
significant most significantly different
from each other in terms of their
importance for changing or dropping
activities it is to improve community
fit and to simplify those are the two
factors that were most important in
adapting and dropping core element
activities now we ask these agencies
about their perceptions of fidelity and
and who what their funders are basically
telling them to do so these are
perceptions of fidelity among agencies
that adapted the intervention and
agencies have implemented it with
fidelity okay so we had some agencies
that said we do it exactly the way they
told us to do it those are implementing
with fidelity then we have those who say
you know we had to change it we had to
make it fit okay all these are
implementers and then we asked them
questions about the agency and all we
have some questions about the
perceptions of what their funders are
telling them so when you look at these
there was no differences between the
adapters and the fidelity high fidelity
agencies and whether or not they were
funded directly by the CDC whether they
received Ryan White funding questions
like I believe it is important to
implement Debbie programs exactly as
implemented by the original researchers
the State Health Department tells
agencies to implement Debbie programs
exactly as the original researchers
implemented the CDC tells agencies to
implement Debbie's exactly as the
original researchers you notice that
these agencies are saying that they're
being told that but not differently
right the perceptions don't differ from
the high fidelity and the adapters ok so
it isn't like the high fidelity guys are
saying yeah yeah we're doing it because
they told us to do it this way any more
than the adapters believe that ok no
differences on agency should remove
activities from a Debbie program low
fidelity the adapters aren't saying that
more
the high-fidelity they're all saying it
a lot right but the one of these
questions that differentiates the
fidelity and the adapting interventions
is this the statement our agency has
difficulty finding evidence based
programs like Debbie's that fit our
community right the high fidelity's
right are less likely to say that than
the adapters and so that's how it's
going on with the Debbie if people are
changing it for community fit beautiful
case study at Harlem United and by the
way I was at the healthy relationships
training when the hilum United guys were
there getting trained and they were good
so the conclusions are most
seventy-eight percent of agencies
trained in healthy relationships
actually implemented that's that's
that's good to know the most common
reason for not implementing was lack of
community fit more than half of those
who implemented made adaptive changes
most often to improve community fit and
behavioral interventions must fit the
community means or they're not going to
be used or they're going to be used
differently than intended and if you
think about technical assistance and
where the CDC should really be putting
their their effort in helping agencies
it's in that area that I know you're
doing a lot of work in which is helping
the intervention fit the community and i
have to say just as sort of an outsider
for a long time I see I've seen CDC
really changed our tune on those you you
guys were much more high fidelity in the
beginning and much more helping to adapt
now and I and I think that's I think for
whatever that's worth I think that's a
good a good thing